You know, one of my earliest memories
as a kid growing up in Jordan
was watching my father,
who was a government engineer at the time,
set up a new computer.
I was just a kid,
but that machine really gripped me.
It felt like it was magic.
We couldn't really afford it,
but my father had a feeling
that this thing
is going to be transformational
for the world and for our lives.
At first, like most kids,
I started playing video games.
I figured out how to boot up video games
and play them for hours.
But then I had a radical thought.
What if I could make my own video games?
The very notion that I could
take a concept in my head
and make it a reality
that I and other people can explore
was something that was really gripping.
Now fast-forward to my teenage years
and the internet has just arrived.
And I thought it was going
to change everything.
I was bursting with business ideas.
But there was a problem.
I didn't know where to start.
Which language do you use?
How do you even share
your creations with the world?
And these questions
sent me down a rabbit hole.
The first thing I attempted doing
at solving these problems
is putting a code editor in the browser.
Can you make it so that you can
code anything really easily
and share it with the world?
So eventually I had a breakthrough.
I built the world's first
online programming sandbox
with a lot of different languages,
and that went viral.
A bunch of companies
in Silicon Valley started using it,
and they hired me.
I got a visa to the United States
and I came to New York.
A few years later, I set eyes to go west
and I came to Silicon Valley
to start a company.
And that was Replit.
Our dream is to make it so that anyone
can turn an idea into software quickly.
Our vision is to empower
a billion software creators.
But giving people an editor
was not going to be enough
to get a billion people coding on it.
We've signed up millions of people
and today we have 25 million developers
registered on our site.
But we need an order of magnitude jump.
And a couple of years ago
I stumbled on this technology.
That's the reason we're all here.
Large language models.
And I thought this was the unlock
that's going to make it possible
for anyone to become a software creator.
The interesting thing
about large language models
is that you can transform
any thought in any language,
any human language,
into software.
And this, I thought, is how we bring
a billion software creators online.
So right now I want you
to imagine something.
Let's say you're traveling in a new city.
And you're walking around
and seeing these magnificent landmarks.
But you're interested in the stories
around these landmarks.
Now it kind of takes you out of the moment
to pull up your phone
and Google and find a Wikipedia page
for that particular landmark.
Wouldn't it be easier if you had a map
with the Wikipedia links
superimposed on the map?
Typically, an app idea like that
will be just a fleeting thought,
and maybe you just forget about it
and continue with your life.
Maybe you'll buy a domain.
And I know I've been guilty
of buying tons of domains
that never turn into anything.
But in the world that I'm envisioning,
you could actually do something
about it in that moment.
You pull out your phone
and you talk to your AI assistant.
And the AI assistant
is not just a passive listener.
It's going to start
brainstorming with you.
It's going to make connections.
It'll find projects
you've worked on in the past
that kind of look like this idea.
And let's say you want
to give a clearer picture.
Well, pull out a napkin. Draw a mark.
Snap a picture
and boom, you send it to your agent.
Let's start strategizing
and thinking of a road map.
Now you don't have a lot of time
to chat with it, you're on the go.
So you send it a voice note.
Now you head home.
And you have a prototype.
You have a tangible thing
that you could actually play with.
You have a starting point
to make an application out of.
But it's not just a prototype.
You also have a plan.
You have a plan of action
that could turn this prototype
into a production app
that you can share with the world.
Now, apps take time and they take money.
So we're going to set a budget
of how much money we're going to spend
and how much time
we're going to spend on this app.
To take a look behind the scenes,
it's not just magic,
although it'll feel magical.
The plan editor becomes a plan source.
It recursively expands
all the different tasks.
It goes out and assembles the tools.
And these are tools that,
as developers, we use every day.
There's your code editor,
your source control
and everything that we're used to.
And you have, of course, the code.
Now this is not just about coding.
It's about a new way
of communicating with technology.
Being able to talk and draw
and work with AI
to make your visions reality.
Let's go back to our plan.
We're going to run it.
It has four feature ideas.
The first one is user auth.
Every app needs that.
The second one is a way
to collect feedback from users.
And the third one
is a way to like places you've been to.
And the fourth one is a navigation.
The first branch is kind of easy.
The AI has seen login pages
a trillion times and knows how to code it.
We'll take a look at the code.
We'll merge it.
The second one is a little bit hard.
Maybe it's a novel task.
But the AI here is prompting us
to add more compute.
So the easiest way to solve this problem
would be to pump in more compute.
Maybe that means a larger model,
or additional contacts
or additional tokens
in order to solve this problem.
And the problem is solved.
The third branch is kind of easy.
Smooth sailing.
I look at it, it works, I merge it.
Now the fourth one is kind of difficult.
The AI seems confident
that it's not going to be able
to solve this problem with more compute.
So it prompts me with an increased budget.
Now it's a hefty number,
and that's because
it's not just going to recruit AIs.
It's going to go out and recruit people.
It's going to post a bounty.
So in this case,
we need a human in the loop.
And until we get AGI,
today, natural intelligence
is going to be really, really important.
So we go out, we get a human.
That quota is going to
also be assisted by AI,
and they're going to help me
solve the problem.
I merge everything together
and it's just a matter of hours
and 50-60 dollars or so,
I have an app I can deploy.
I deploy it, I share it with the world.
Now to step back a little bit,
notice that I didn't write
a single line of code.
I was basically the creative
heartbeat of the project.
I manage the project,
I manage both AI and people,
mediated by AI
in order to build this application.
And that fleeting thought that you had
is suddenly an application.
So, you know, I can almost hear
some of you thinking, like,
"OK, Amjad, this is this is great and all.
This is a fascinating vision
but it kind of looks
too fantastic, two futuristic."
Well, I'm here to tell you
it's kind of already happening.
So just a couple of weeks ago,
an entrepreneur on Replit, Yoeri --
he's a technical recruiter by training,
he's not a software engineer --
he learned enough code
to start building his startup.
And thousands of miles
across the world we have Akashdeep.
Akashdeep, a student in India,
he comes from a farming family
and he can't afford a PC.
He has never had a PC.
All he's had was his Android phone.
He started learning to code in Replit
just a few months ago,
and then decided to go
and start making money on the platform.
Now he makes more money
than his entire family
and he can afford a lot
of different computers, not just one.
And now he's joined forces
with Yoeri to build that startup.
You know, today we talk
about the Fortune 500,
and it takes a ton of employees
to build a big company like that.
But I think in the future,
when AI is helping everyone
build their dreams,
we’re going to be talking
about the Fortune 5000000.
And again, this is not just --
This is not just a fantasy.
We're already building this.
Last week we announced
that we're open-sourcing our AI models,
and we're making it free for all our users
because we think that's a massive step up
for all of humanity.
AI is not just a tool, it's a ladder
that equalizes opportunity.
And that opens up horizons for people
that are typically on the sidelines.
So I'll leave you with this.
Imagine that
the American dream,
not just --
not just in one place,
but actually in the cloud.
Thank you.
(Applause)